The weaving cast-on is a quick
and easy way to start your knitting.
This cast-on is not appropriate
for garment edge, but it is a fast way
to start with waste yarn and ravel cord.
When it's complete,
you'll see a single strand of yarn
running through the first row of stitches.
Let's get started.
Pull out the desired number of needles.
With no yarn in the carriage,
run it across the bed to align
the needles in working position.
With your needle pusher,
pull every other needle all the way out.
Engage both weaving brushes
and end up with the carriage on the right.
Now you can thread your
carriage with your cast-on yarn.
Now grab the tail of yarn that's coming
from under the carriage and place it
across the top of all the needles.
Hold the tail on the left-hand
side and knit across.
Hang a cast-on comb and a little weight.
This will help form that first row
of stitches and continue knitting.
You can disengage your
weaving brushes now.
They're only used on that cast-on row.
This is a very loose cast-on,
but it's perfect for swatching or any time
you want to get a very quick
start on your knitting.